[Music]
right so i was
i was in my japanese class as i do learn
japanese not very successfully as always
but yeah you know i'm just i turn up
you know yeah you're there i'm helping
i'm here i'm helping
uh and i was uh in in the break time we
get like a
five minute break i don't know why it's
only two hours i don't really feel like
you need a break for two hours and you
know whatever anyway
so we get a break and we're chilling in
like the lounge area it's like that kind
of hip
a lounge they have like a kind of it's
like this like fake
hip college kind of air it's like yeah
[ __ ] what you want man like
everything's a chair and so uh
i was just sitting and then uh i was
talking with my teacher and then a guy
right next to me like here is like hey
uh do i know you
do it don't you i'm like that's always
the worst
no i'm like i don't know he's like
you're a youtuber right
i have my mask on bear in mind as well
right right and i was like
yeah yeah i guess that's me i just
stared at him i was like i was so caught
off guard i know what to say
so i just i was just like i looked dead
in that like the mike wazowski meme
again i love that meme i just looked at
him like yeah i guess
yeah just stared at him
and then i was like oh no that was
pretty funny thinks of an [ __ ] now so
if you're watching this i'm i'm sorry
uh i just stared at you blankly when you
recognized
wait wait so he came up to you and was
like you're the youtuber right and you
said yeah and then he just didn't say
anything or he was like
uh he's like oh yeah i think i've seen
your stuff and i was like oh thanks
i i love it when you like get recognized
and they they come over and i'm like hey
you're
you're that guy right and then you say
yeah and then you kind of see the
realization on their face that they
didn't plan the conversation out
at any any point after they said that
you know what i mean it's just because
like i didn't expect it like
in my japanese class in like you know
yeah yeah yeah i
i mean there's a lot of foreigners there
admittedly yeah but it's something like
a lot older people than me
so i just didn't expect it yeah what is
up with some people who are just like oh
he's a youtuber he'll leave the
conversation on right afterwards i
didn't mind i felt bad because i felt
like i should have been like
oh man how are you doing or something
because i was just like yeah
because when you get recognized not at
an anime convention right because i feel
like when you get recognized in an anime
version
you're like you're like in the zone
you're like oh yeah i'm expecting this i
i like know how to handle this but when
it's just out on the streets
irl it's like not near a connection yeah
yeah daily life yeah just in your daily
life you just get blindsided
yeah because because you get caught
during like your off period yeah because
like at a con you're always on your own
period where you're like all right
there's people around me people are
looking for
yeah yeah yeah like not to be like
egotistical but at the con you know
there's gonna be some people like
yeah anime mentioned yeah yeah i know
you so you're like ready for it yeah
but you know when i'm just at my school
or on the gym
it's like the last thing that's in my
head is that i'm a youtuber right i'm
just thinking like i should get my
[ __ ] day over
i was like the time where i got
recognized by it was the first
time i was ever recognized by like a
straight-up japanese person like
can't speak the word of english japan
and it was a [ __ ] salary man in like
his mid 40s and i when he like tapped me
on the shoulder and i turned around
there was just this like mid-40s like
like borderline ugly bastard looking
[ __ ] that poor guy
i'm serious it was like borderline ugly
bastard looking guy i was just like
oh no i'm in danger i mean that's right
i'm in danger and then in japanese he
was like oh you're uh you're that
youtuber who collabed with kids in the
eye
right and it immediately knows you yeah
immediately i was like
uh you're a kid's not iphone yeah of
course you are you
look like a youtuber fan and so i said
like
defending all the future call me out
like that jerry
it's like you look like a japanese v
tuber fan and so i was like yeah yeah i
did
because i think it was like maybe one or
two weeks after i did my first collab
with kizunai yeah and that was like a
really big
thing for me where i got a lot of
japanese eyes on me because before that
you know because i don't really speak in
japanese on my channel right japanese
people aren't subscribed to my [ __ ]
yeah but when i was on kids channel
because i spoke japanese
i got a lot of like japanese people who
you know came to my channel obviously
and
this salary man was like oh i uh after i
saw your collab with kids now i
oh sorry no he said so i was like oh
yeah you're definitely a fan
but after i saw you collab with aijan i
i subscribed to your channel
and i was like oh do do you understand
like can you speak english yeah he's
like no
but i watch your videos to learn english
and i was like
hmm just in the back of my head i was
like going through my instagram
horrible [ __ ] i'm just like i'm pretty
sure i say [ __ ] like every three words
in my videos i'm like i don't know and
so jokingly i was like oh yeah
i mean my videos aren't the best to
learn english with and in a straight
face he's like no actually i've learned
a lot
from your videos
but yeah that was scary dude have you
ever been recognized by a japanese
person yeah i've been recognized
once by a japanese person in japan it
was like the most random place because i
think um
i can't remember what day it was but i
think i was like on a date with sydney
um somewhere in japan and we went to
this like random italian restaurant
right
it was like a like a local run italian
restaurant
but it was like run by a japanese person
and we come in and
for some reason the japanese person was
just like the the guy
waitering us was just like super super
nice
we thought he was just like this over
enthusiastic japanese person
yeah he was like trying to speak english
to us and everything and we're like oh
man
this is a really nice restaurant i don't
know if they're just nice to everyone
here yeah
and then we get the bill and he puts on
like this massive
discount on it right and we're like um
there must be a mistake we got like the
wrong bill or something yeah
we go up to the so we go up to the guy
trying to speak like our broken japanese
just say like this is
this is wrong this is the wrong price
yeah he goes like uh
he also like communicates in like broken
english and japanese being like
oh no like i just wanted to say thank
you for like everything you've done
you you've like i watch your videos to
help again
learn english and i'm like
man why are our videos being used as a
resource to learn english there are so
many good videos out there where you can
actually learn english
don't use anituber videos to learning
yeah that's never a good idea
although i don't know like i feel like
whenever i if i ever get to meet a
youtuber and i'm like
man thank you for helping me learn
japanese
i'm wondering if they're going to like
have the same kind of reaction on the
other side
that's like the uh that's like the uh
that uh
cashier at the family mine near our
house is like
a fan of my videos and every now and
then like if when i go to the family mod
near my house
uh late at night and he's working there
late at night he's sometimes just like
yo come here and he like leads me to the
cash register and he's like
all this chicken in here we're gonna
throw it out they give you do you just
want some
and he just gives me the free [ __ ]
family matching i'm like
yeah sure why not this is probably gonna
kill me but it's all right
i'll take some free chicken yeah shout
out to you by the way